Let's talk a little bit about
the structure of the cell.
I've done a lot
of videos where we
deal with things that
go on inside of them,
but I haven't done
one where we just
talk about the entire
structure of them.
So a good place to start is--
let me just draw the membrane.
And the cellular membrane
is a good place to start,
because this is what
separates the cell
from the outside world.
And to a large degree, it
kind of defines the cell.
It defines it as this very,
very small compartment.
That's where the
word cell came from.
So let me label that.
Cellular membrane.
And all cells have
a cellular membrane.
Now, if we think about maybe
the most important thing that
defines a cell-- you've
probably seen in the DNA videos,
and we'll talk about translation
and transcription and all that.
But what defines what a
living organism is is its DNA,
so all cells have
DNA inside of it.
And I won't go into
the detail of how
DNA defines what an organism is.
I've done that in some
detail on the DNA videos,
but all cells have DNA here.
This is more of kind
of an anatomy of a cell
video than necessarily
the function.
But we'll go into the
function, because we
need to know what these
different parts do.
So right here, this is the DNA.
And it's in its
chromatin form here.
There's also little proteins
here, not in all organisms.
But we're going to
stick to eukaryotes,
and I'll talk a little
bit about the difference
between eukaryotes and
prokaryotes in a second.
But we have DNA.
As I've drawn this
cell right now,
this is pretty much any cell,
any cell in any animal or plant
or whatever kingdom
could look like this.
I haven't drawn a
lot of the details.
I've just drawn the DNA
and the cellular membrane.
Now, here is kind of the first
major division in the living
world, or at least
from our point of view,
or it seemed obvious,
is that some cells have
a membrane around the DNA.
So they'll have a membrane
around the DNA that
separates the DNA and the
chromatin and everything that
makes up the stuff
within the DNA,
separates that from
the rest of the cell.
And this is called a nucleus.
And I said that's
a major division,
because when some people
looked at some cells
and they saw a nucleus
and other cells
and they didn't see a
nucleus, they say, hey,
this is a good way to
classify organisms.
So they called the things
that had nucleuses eukaryotes.
These have a nucleus.
So as I've drawn this cell
right here, it is a eukaryote.
Now, if you do not
have a nucleus,
you are dealing
with a prokaryote.
No nucleus.
And examples of prokaryotes,
the two big groups of them,
are bacteria and archaea.
And archaea are
really interesting.
We know very, very
little about them.
They were originally thought
to be types of bacteria,
but now people are
realizing that they're
this whole completely
other group.
And we've actually observed
a very small subset of them,
so it's a very
fascinating group.
And actually it turns out
that evolutionarily speaking,
you shouldn't make
this division first.
And it actually makes more
sense to divide things
into eukaryotes.
I'll just write that.
Euk, bacteria, and archaea.
You don't want to do
this division first.
There are actually
three separate groups
that you want to start
off with, archaea.
We'll do that, we'll talk more
about this in future videos.
But if you want to say
who was a nucleus, well,
eukaryotes have a
nucleus by definition.
Who does not have a nucleus?
Well, the bacteria
and the archaea
do not have nuclei,
just like that.
But I'm going to focus on
eukaryotes, because they
tend to be a little
bit more complex.
They tend to be larger.
And most of what we talk about,
at least in the videos so far,
are dealing with eukaryotes.
Eukaryotes include
plants, animals.
We're animals.
At least I am.
Animals and fungi.
And there are other
groups within eukaryotes,
but these are the
ones that we normally
deal with in our everyday world.
Let's go back to looking
at the anatomy itself.
So we have our DNA.
We know that it gets
transcribed into mRNA.
That mRNA leaves
the nucleus, and it
gets translated into
proteins at the ribosomes.
So the ribosomes are
these little complexes
that could be floating
all over the cell,
and we'll see in a
second that they can also
be attached to these
other membrane structures.
So this is a ribosome.
And if all this talk
of DNA transcription
into mRNA and mRNA
leaving the nucleus
and traveling to the ribosome
to be translated into proteins
makes no sense to you,
there are several videos
where I go into that in detail.
But what I want to
do is just focus on
all of the different
parts, kind of give
a big picture of things.
So ribosomes are
where mRNA that gets
transcribed inside
the nucleus from DNA
where it gets translated
into proteins.
So you can kind of
view them as a place
where information actually
turns into proteins which
then can be used anywhere
else in the cell.
Now, one interesting--
and these ribosomes,
they're made up of proteins.
And actually, they're
made up of RNA.
And so one question
is, well, where
are the pieces of
the ribosomes made?
Well, some of them
are made by proteins,
which might be made
in other ribosomes.
But some of it, the mRNA,
ribosomes, you can kind of
view them as this big mass
if you were to look detailed.
There's some protein there.
And I'm not drawing
it that realistically,
but then you have some mRNA
tied in with the protein.
And the mRNA isn't used for
actual information purposes
like it normally is when it
goes from DNA to the ribosome.
Within the ribosome
itself, ribosomal RNA
is actually used as
part of the structure.
It actually helps the ribosome
function as a ribosome,
so it's actually
part of the ribosome.
And all of that gets built
in a part of the nucleus
called the nucleolus
or the nucleole.
Let me write that down.
So this right here, this
is interesting right here.
This is the nucleolus
or the nucleole.
And it isn't a
separate organelle,
and it's not separated
by a membrane.
But it shows up in a microscope.
So when people first saw that,
hey, there's like a bundle
there.
That must be like the core
of the nucleus or something.
But it turns out
what it is, it's
the densely packed--
you got DNA and RNA.
And that's actually where the
ribosomal RNA, the stuff that
makes up the ribosomes,
is actually produced.
But it's so dense that it
shows up on a microscope,
and that's why people decided
to name it something different.
But it is not membrane bound.
It's not an organelle
within an organelle.
It's just densely packed
proteins and ribosomal RNA.
It's where ribosomal
RNA gets produced.